hòa sẽ bị tất cả các khi chúng tôi kêu kêu kêu chấm như thế này.
Và tong tạng lớp, và nướt thái người chúng tôi đang gố gắng.
Phái sự dục tùng phàn kế nước, phải đàn.
Và chúng ta sẽ dùng lại và chúng ta sẽ...
...cố gắng, sử dưới, chân nó tùng phàn, nó đẹp.
Đừng có cái gì chúng ta có thể dùng tờ lại.
Chúng tôi còn phối hợp cùng với thật hẹn.
Các đô tế, mình đang dính vất sân.
Vì dùng như là chúng ta đã mởi khi chúng ta nằm mởi ngành kê sân của người cô, kè tô tạc.
Lẹ làm sân hòa lên.
Một dư, lãm sao đo khách thái đồng là thắp xuống.
Để vật thật đĩnh, chung thí thủ, phật thư, chung thội nhằm đến.
Hình hình này để chung thội nhớ đến tất cả, kè gửi nửi.
Mình rất đàn đẹp.
Các đồng, tất cả đồng, tất cả đúng sẵn với dùng như là kè chạm.
Các đồng là hóc là có người cơ thái thật thái lớp.
và đều nhìn đang một trực vì gần liên trực của thông gòn thủ hỗng báo viê này bây giờ
ở cây như cái một têu
cùng với chính phủ cùng với
nhé lớp của mình cùng với
chứ hướng thịt dựa cái ngay
để kê lọt
tựa những thông gòn những cái
của giẻ thông nghệ phát triển